the government's own analysis shows that
under a reasonable worst case scenario a
no deal brexit would reduce our supply
but increase the price of food medicines
petrol electricity
and compromise our national security but
it's all just project fear right
because there wasn't such an initial
shock after the referendum result was
announced
all warnings about brexit must just be
scaremongering
why this isn't some campaign group
trying to thwart the will of the people
this is the pm's civil servants boris
johnson didn't study international trade
he studied greek
poetry the professionals he relies on to
know what to expect from a no deal
brexit
are saying that it would ruin the lives
of the people he has a duty
to protect during the 2016 referendum
boris johnson didn't even acknowledge
the idea of a no deal brexit as an
option
why because he knows that every country
in the wto has a trade deal with its
neighbors
he knows that people are smart enough to
see that doing something that every
other successful economy in the world
has chosen not to do
would obviously hurt us he knows that
nobody would vote for that and yet
here we are
don't know what you don't understand
this is a worst case scenario
it is not a prediction let me tell you
about my morning this morning
i woke up and i had to take a couple of
steps to my bathroom i could
i could have fallen down those steps and
broken my leg either went in the shower
there's electricity and there's water
going to the shop that could have
electrocuted me i could have shaved
myself i could have cut myself shaving
i got in a car i could have not my car
he could have crashed we could have gone
into the side of the bus
could could could this is a completely
slanted and biased document
ian duncan smith appeared on my radio
show this morning on lbc
and broke the terms of the privy council
which andrew is a political veteran
he'll know all about that
he broke the terms of the privy council
to point out that when he was shown this
a month or so ago
he said to the people because they were
talking about the impact i think it's
0.3 the impact in our ports
and he said what have they said at
calais
what what have they told it and there
was a silence so ian douglas has said
you have spoken to the people in calais
have you about the new they hadn't
even spoken to the people of calais i
put it to the yellow hammer is
absolutely twisted absolutely biased
of course we should be aware of the
concerns but realize what it was set up
to do
let's put it this way you're saying that
it's all just it could happen could
happen let's go with actual facts
where does the majority of the fish that
we catch go where did half of the cars
that we manufacture
go where's the third of the welsh
laminate wheat that we farm go
eu countries does doesn't no deal brexit
force the eu to put tariffs on all of
those products
yes do they currently face tariffs now
no so isn't it is it not
absolutely definitely sure that there
will be
barriers at those borders no sorry no
there there were trade there weren't
trade buyers before there are trade
barriers now
and you're saying that it will be fine
we don't know what the deal is we don't
know what
it is but we're not going out
necessarily with a no deal but this is
the worst
i don't know what you understand the
worst case scenario
not a prediction there's a difference
you know nick at one point i would have
agreed with what you're saying in the
sense that i would have seen this as
some
very fringe outcome that all sensible
people would have agreed we would avoid
it would have seemed like the extreme
that i wouldn't expect to ever happen
the difference between what i thought
then and what i thought now is
two years of failing to get a deal
through parliament and boris johnson
clearly and his own cabinet ministers
and his own brother have suggested that
he's not seriously pursuing a deal at
this point we are
in serious danger facing a deal brexit
it's not it's not some
it's nikki morgan resigned from cabinet
because she said
pursuing a deal was not being done in
anywhere near as serious
away as the option of a no deal it is
something we are realistically facing it
is not a fringe
because nicki morgan who is a remainer
has stayed in the cabinet she said she
will continue to fight in the cabinet
she thinks no deal should be kept as an
option because it's the best negotiating
tactic we've got but i want to go back
to what femi said
in his introduction you said because the
predictions
which i would call in project fear
weren't as bad just remind you what the
chancellor george osborne said
during that referendum there would be an
immediate and profound
economic shock if we voted to leave who
wrote those
forecasts for him the very civil
servants who've written this
utterly discredited document it is
project theory at large just because it
came out of the government
the white hall is remain dominated we uh
the the civil servants who were running
it for mrs may remained dominated it was
a remain dominated cabinet
and that's why i think nick is quite
right it is worst
case uh assumptions it is not a
prediction again you're basically
you're saying that because these people
said this blah blah blah again i'll go
with it i'll go with the facts
why don't you answer the point i made
about a profound a profound and
immediate economic shock let me remind
you what we saw in the last week
in the last week the best unemployment
figures in this country
for 45 years economic growth in july
up 0.3 percent and the highest wage
growth in the economy
since 2008 the year of the credit crunch
it wasn't just that the except the
warnings were exaggerated
they were made up yeah and i think
they're still made up in this project
so for starters wage wage job creation
has slowed
as for what what concrete 45 year in 45
years
the point is i'm going to give you a
concrete example there is a factory in
sunderland that sends 70 of its cars to
mainland europe to other eu countries
now if there's a tariff barrier between
us and we send the majority of our cars
if there's differences in regulation
between us and when we said the majority
of our cars if you were nissan
you have a choice keep your factory here
70 of your cars are
going to face an extra cost put your
factory in frankfurt only third percent
of your car is going to face an extra
cost
where would you put that factory and
what happens to those 35 000 jobs across
the northeast
i was contacted um the other day and i'm
sure it's still there
um online and also on my social media by
from somebody
um a gentleman who contacted me publicly
to say how
um the the fear of no deal that he was
feeling
was really damaging his mental health he
then went on to explain to me when i
asked him what he meant
he fears that we're gonna have a risk of
famine in this country
and he genuinely genuinely believed that
and the situation that we're in now and
um
i do i find it deeply frustrating is
that we are
in a negotiation the fact that um boris
johnson has had his hand tied hands tied
by removing no deal is
beyond backward in my mind i cannot no
matter how much people try and explain
it to me
i cannot ever and will not ever share
the rationale of removing no deal from
the table
when i see this document i actually
think it is
vaguely sensible in some of its contents
its specific reason
is to consider as a contingency plan
what may happen and as nick said
i may leave this studio and get hit by a
car i don't mean i'm going to sit
forever in this studio
it means i'll take my chances and look
both ways when i leave
you you have all suggested that the
civil service should be discredited
andrew you said
their their pro remain if we discredit
the civil service who by the way are the
people paid to advise government or
whichever party on reasonable outcomes
what do you accept as the potential
outcome of a no deal and michelle just
to
to talk about you saying no deal should
be on the table parliament
for two years accepted no deal being on
the table as a negotiating strategy
it's only when we have a month to go
just over a month to go until the brexit
date and no deal
that parliament is taking action to
prevent a no deal brexit how is that
because mrs may
mrs may we now know in all those
negotiations while she was prime
minister
never ever raised the specter of no deal
in her negotiations with michele
she never played the best ace in the
package
did nothing to stop halfway putting no
differentiation as the crucial point of
a negotiation is when you're approaching
the deadline
so no matter negotiations of course
now let's be really clear on this what
does no deal actually do it makes trade
with our 27 closest markets more
expensive
from the eu's perspective it's trade
with one of their closest market which
comes more expensive so mathematically
no deal hurts us more than it hurts the
eu so the idea that we have
leverage by doing something that hurts
us more never going to work
now the idea that it's project fear i'm
going to take both of you up
on things that you said in 2016. you
tweeted um
on what is it the 22nd of february
hate scaremongering we re being safer in
the eu
terrorism intelligence surely any
country and would share
this information regardless of a
political union whereas a no deal brexit
means we're no longer in the eu system
regarding data protection which is why
they can't share that information
i stand by and it's you really need to
get out more if you've got nothing
better to do then go back
through to them all of my tweets and i
hope you found some riveting stuff in
there
more interesting than that tweet but i
stand by that point
i do not believe that in a situation for
example when
spain has um a vision of a terrorist
that may be coming into england
and maybe wanting to do some terrorist
attack i do not believe that they will
sit there and say oh
cat one england
how intelligent sharing works you don't
wait until the point where you have
a silver bullet you share intelligence
gradually over the course of time
there is a reason why across europe
after the second world war we recognize
the need to pull our resources to
prevent war
and to share intelligence gradually
every day the mechanisms of european
intelligence sharing
which by the way i've studied
that is the biggest intelligence
gathering biggest monitoring in the
entire world
the eu and i am absolutely convinced the
uk will continue to share
it that is far more a one-way street the
eu need the intelligence that the uk get
from the u.s the idea you think that's
going to cease
one final thing with andrew with
anything with andrew you said
another remain lie exposed german cbi
says there will be no hikes and trade
barriers
if we if we leave vote leave well we
said vote keep actually but yeah
um that is a no deal a no deal forces
the eu to put tariffs on uk products and
i just mentioned a lot of the stuff we
make
goes there so again the breaks that you
said people voting for in 2016
is not no deal you tell me that
britain's got a lot to fear from the
from from no deal
you go over to ireland and talk to them
about the prospect of no deal so up to
the eu they had plenty of chances to
give us a decent deal and they didn't
and as and as michelle said we're
sending our prime minister
into the debating chamber with his hands
tied behind his back and a certain prime
minister who said that
was john major in the 1997 general
election and i was there when he said it